foreign
cancellation is special to me indeed I
think it's probably special to the
entire world
um some will even say that it is sacred
and I consider it a privilege but also
an important responsibility to cancel
someone at the end of every show every
day Forever Until the End of Time but on
rare occasion very very rare occasion I
find it necessary to dedicate this
portion of the show to something other
than canceling some evil doer and
usually this happens when there's
something else I want to talk about for
10 minutes but I can't find any other
space for it in the show so that's how
we end up here anyway the point is that
today is one of those very rare days so
I want to tell you about a man named
Oliver Anthony he's a blue collar guy
lives way out in the sticks in Virginia
basically Off the Grid in his free time
he likes to play and sing songs that he
writes for the past few years he's been
occasionally recording his songs on his
phone posting into his YouTube channel
which had maybe a few hundred
subscribers and his videos would get
maybe a few dozen or a few hundred views
but that has changed rather suddenly
over the last few days this man in his
music have gone massively viral thanks
primarily to one song of his called
Richmond rich men north of Richmond
which made its way from YouTube to
Twitter where it caught fire
in the video of him performing this song
while standing in the woods in front of
his deer stand has now been viewed
millions of times the song is currently
trending Nationwide on Twitter and he's
even had public offers including from
our friend John Rich to produce and
distribute a studio album
Oliver Anthony has has gone from Full
obscurity about his obscure as a musical
artist can possibly be playing songs in
the Woods by himself
to musical Fame in the span of like two
days and it's a great story the best
part is the song that has driven all of
this and uh there are a few points to
make about that but first let's play a
clip of the song here it is
I've been selling my soul
Soul working all day
over time hours
bullsh hey so I can sit out here and
waste my life away drag back home and
down my troubles away it's a damn shame
what the world's gotten to for people
like me people like you wish I could
just wake up and not be true but it is
all it is living in the new world
Soul
these rich men North the Richmond Lord
knows it all just wanna have total
control wanna know what you think wanna
know what you do and they don't think
you know but I know that you do cause
your dollar ain't
X-Men
[Music]
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not just miners on an island
somewhere Lord we got folks in the
street ain't got nothing to eat and the
whole base milk and Welfare but God if
you're five foot three and you're 300
pounds taxes ought not to pay for your
bags of fudge rounds young men are
putting themselves six feet in the
ground cause all this damn country does
is keep on kicking them down
okay so that's a club event now first
needless to say I love the song this is
my kind of music I can listen to this
sort of stuff all day just a guy with a
beard standing in the woods singing
about his troubles and playing the
guitar that's my vibe as the kids would
say it's also what all country music
should sound like instead of sounding as
it so often does like generic pop music
with a slight twang most country music
these days like all other kinds of
popular music sound like it was you know
it sounds like it was made by by an
algorithm not a person and this song on
the other hand sounds raw and real and
human
but it's interesting that a song like
this has become an internet sensation
because normally when you hear about a
song that's gone viral you assume that
it must be Taylor Swift singing for the
90th time about one of her ex-boyfriends
or maybe another rap song about the
female anatomy or whatever you imagine a
song that people can dance to in Tick
Tock videos which they record in public
somewhere like at the grocery store
while confused Shoppers look on you
don't necessarily imagine a low-tech low
budget recording of a folk song where a
bearded guy stands in the woods and
sings about the pain of being a working
class American
so why has this one caught on well I
think there are two reasons first of all
it you know it's it's uh
just good music Oliver Oliver Anthony
has Raw Talent sometimes the combination
of good music raw talent is hard to
ignore
second it's it's the message you know
Anthony is singing about the Forgotten
American uh the the working class man
who breaks his back all day only to have
his pockets picked by the IRS while the
people in charge of this country ignore
his concerns and spit in his face
whenever he tries to convey them
is speaking out for people who don't
have a voice and although There's real
poetry in his lyrics he's expressing
those concerns using the same language
that they would use
Innovation refunds has been helping
small businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through
their employee retention credit or also
known as the ERC the ERC is a tax refund
for businesses that kept employees on
payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021. if
you own a business with more than five
employees you could have money waiting
to be claimed but you got to claim it
the ERC tax filing is complex Innovation
refunds is dedicated then to helping
business owners navigate the process let
their Team guide you through the
remaining steps to find out if you're
eligible partner with their dedicated
team of independent tax attorneys to
complete your ERC application with
confidence and peace of mind today
Innovation refunds does not provide tax
or legal advice they work with an
independent network of tax professionals
and will share information with them to
evaluate and process your claims go to
getrefunds.com to determine your
eligibility if you qualify you could be
on your way to receiving money for your
business there's no upfront charge since
they don't get paid unless you get paid
go to getrefunds.com or dial 1-843
refunds that's getrefunds.com 1-843
refunds terms and conditions apply
many Americans have lost faith in the
government media schools that's the bad
news the good news is that there's
something you can do to help get the
country back on track prageru is an
educational non-profit that is fighting
to save the future of America and we've
been working closely with prageru for
many years and I did my first prageru
video I think that was a long time seven
or eight years ago and uh it's been
great to watch them only grow in the
meantime watch five million times a day
prageru videos spread messages of
Liberty economic freedom and
judeo-christian values to the Next
Generation there truly is hope for
America but only if we reach more young
people and prageru needs your help doing
that go to prageru.com make a tax
deductible donation whatever you give
right now will be matched and have twice
the impact donate ten dollars it doubles
it twenty dollars give fifty it becomes
a hundred you get the idea 70 of viewers
say that their mind was changed after
watching a prageru video please give to
preview today so your gift can have
double the impact in reaching more
people and changing more Minds go to
prageru.com today whatever you give will
be doubled
now we hear so much about the the need
for representation in our culture but
the fact is that there are millions of
people who are not represented anywhere
not in media not in Hollywood not in
popular music not in government nowhere
and those are the people who look and
live like Oliver Anthony
it's also worth noting I think it's
interesting those lines that's why I
wanted to play that much of it so you
could hear the lines at the end
um the the lines about the wealth
welfare state
um this song is being called a populist
Anthem which it is I think it may be it
may become the protest song of this
generation
but conventional wisdom says that
attacking entitlements attacking welfare
is not populist in fact we're told if
you really care about people like Oliver
Anthony you should defend entitlement
programs and insist that we should
continue spending hundreds of billions
on them
but the truth is that guys like Anthony
they work all day to provide for
themselves and their own families
they're not fans of the fact that their
money is being taken from them food is
being taken out of their children's
mouths in order to prop up this system
of entitlements that really functions as
nothing more than a vote buying scheme
for Democrats okay go up to almost any
guy at any bar in any blue collar part
of the country
and ask them about welfare and they will
say something very similar to what
Anthony says in that song
almost all of them will and yet
Republicans are afraid to even mention
the subject for fear that they'll lose
the votes of the very people who are
being scammed by this system
I said there are two reasons why the
song's uh popular actually there are
three so I lied because there's
something else too
um it's not just that the message is
resonating I think there's something
deeper too it's it's authenticity okay
people in this country are starved
for authenticity
everything is fake right every
everything around us is fake the music
is all basically computer generated the
movies are full of CGI most of what you
see on the news is fake most of what you
find on social media is fake we've got
filters and Photoshop and Ai and deep
fakes
we're just surrounded by artificiality
we're drowning in and that's why a video
of a guy pouring his heart out while he
plays his guitar in the woods in front
of his deer stand with his dogs laying
there in the grass and the cicadas
buzzing in the background that's why it
resonates with people it's like it's a
it's a glass of cool water for people
who are thirsting for something real
and that's why it went viral
and and also again it's just good music
it's simply good music and maybe it
doesn't need to be any more complicated
than that
and for all those reasons
Oliver Anthony is today certainly not
canceled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there